>>> IN OUR POLITICS LET, FEWER
THAN TEN WEEKS BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS WHERE ELECTION
DENIERS IN KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES COULD FIND THEMSELVES IN
CONTROL.
ON SATURDAY, MICHIGAN
REPUBLICANS NOMINATED TWO
TRUMP-BACKED ELECTION DENIERS
FOR KEY STATE-WIDE OFFICES.
IN ARIZONA, CNN FOUND THE FAR
RIGHT SECRETARY OF STATE NOMINEE
KEPT A TREASON WATCH LIST.
AND IN PENNSYLVANIA, THE GOP
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR WAS ALSO
A KEY FIGURE IN TRUMP'S BID TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
CNN'S KYUNG LAH WENT TO NEVADA
WHERE TWO 2020 ELECTION DENIERS
HAVE ALREADY CHANGED THE WAY THE
2022 MIDTERM BALLOTS WILL BE
COUNTED.
>> IN THE THINLY POPULATED
DESERT A FEW HOURS OUTSIDE OF
LAS VEGAS, NEVADA, SITS NYE
COUNTY WHERE 2020 ELECTION LIES
ARE NOW A TENANT OF THEIR FAITH.
>> WHEN DONALD TRUMP SAYS THAT
HE BELIEVES HE WON THE 2020
ELECTION, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'M WITH HIM.
I'M WITH HIM, DEFINITELY.
>> THESE VOTERS USHERED IN THE
PRAND NEW NYE COUNTY CLERK.
>> I'M THE DOER WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT.
>> HE IS OVERHAULING HOW BALLOTS
ARE COUNTED IN NEVADA'S MIDTERM
IN CHARGE OF THE COUNTY'S
MIDTERM ELECTION.
BUT IN A DEBATE EARLIER THIS
YEAR, HE SAID THIS.
>> I BELIEVE THAT DONALD TRUMP
WON THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> YOU STILL BELIEVE THAT?
>> WHAT I BELIEVE AS CLERK HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT I
BELIEVE AS CANDIDATE.
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING THE NYE
COUNTY CLERK, AND AS THE NYE
COUNTY CLERK, I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR TOTAL IMPARTIALITY.
>> IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THE
SYSTEM WAS LEGITIMATE IN 2020
AND CREATED AN ERROR WHERE
30,000 PLUS VOTES WERE NOT
COUNTED IN THE STATE CORRECTLY,
ISN'T THAT PROBLEMATIC?
>> I DON'T SEE IT AS BEING
PROBLEMATIC AT ALL BECAUSE I'M
TRYING TO INCREASE VOTER
CONFIDENCE IN THE ELECTION.
>> THE SYSTEM HE PLANS TO USE IN
NOVEMBER, PAPER BALLOTS,
FOLLOWED BY A HAND COUNT.
WHY?
DISTRUST OF MACHINES.
DRIVEN BY 2020 CONSPIRATORIAL
LIES ABOUT DOMINION.
IN THE ELECTION SPACE, THE
MACHINES THAT COUNT GO THROUGH
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF SECURITY.
THEY ARE NOT CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET.
AND THIS IS REGULATED THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
>> THAT'S A PERSPECTIVE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
AGAIN, THE VOTERS IN THIS COUNTY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
AND WHETHER IT'S TRUE OR NOT,
THEIR PERCEPTION IS THEIR
REALITY.
>> HE SAYS HE WILL STILL USE
DOMINION MACHINES IN A PARALLEL
COUNT AND COMPARE THE RESULTS.
>> WHAT WOULD SEEM LIKE A CRAZY
INTERNET PLAN SEEMS TO BE COMING
TO REALITY AND IT SHOULD BE A
FIVE-ALARM FIRE FOR ANYONE WHO
CARES ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
>> ELECTION CONSPIRACY THEORISTS
ARE ALREADY RUNNING VOTING IN
THIS SWING STATE.
>> IN RURAL COUNTIES IN NEVADA
WHAT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE IS AN
ATTEMPT BY FRINGE ELEMENTS TO
REALLY TAKE CONTROL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES BY INTERFERING WITH
DEMOCRACY.
>> WHAT'S PROBLEMATIC ABOUT HAND
COUNTING?
>> ALL IT'S GOING TO DO IS GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAMPER
WITH AN ELECTION.
THIS IS A COORDINATED MACHINE
THAT'S IN PLACE.
>> YOUR NAME, SIR?
>> JIM MARCHAND FROM LAS VEGAS,
NEVADA.
>> MARCHAND IS A REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE FOR SECRETARY OF STATE.
FOR MONTH HE'S BEEN GOING FROM
RURAL COUNTY TO COUNTY.
>> WE'RE HERE TO RECOMMEND THAT
YOU VOTE TODAY TO DISPOSE OF
YOUR ELECTRONIC VOTING AND
TABULATION MACHINES.
>> WE CAUGHT UP WITH HIM AT ONE
OF HIS MANY TRAINING EVENTS
WHERE ATTENDEES ARE TOLD VARIOUS
ELECTION CONSPIRACIES AS FACTS.
TELL ME ABOUT HAND COUNTING AND
YOUR EFFORT IN THE RURAL
COUNTIES.
>> JUST TRYING TO IMPLEMENT A
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT ELECTION.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED IN
THE 2020 ELECTION?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY WHEN ELECTION
OFFICIALS ACROSS THE COUNTRY SAY
THAT NONE OF THIS IS TRUE?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THEM.
WE JUST DIFFER IN OPINION.
OR DIFFER IN, YEAH, WHAT WE
BELIEVE.
.
>> DOZENS UPON DOZENS OF
ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE WRONG,
YOU'RE SAYING?
>> YES.
>> MARCHAND NOR THE NEVADA GOP
WOULD LET US IN TO LISTEN TO HIS
PRESENTATION.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE EVENT IS
CLOSED TO THE PRESS.
>> THIS IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
ELECTION FOR DEMOCRACY, I WOULD
IMAGINE, IN NEVADA PROBABLY IN
HISTORY.
THE PLAYBOOK IS BEING DRAFTED AS
IT'S MOVING FORWARD.
I WOULD SAY THAT 2022 IN NEVADA
SHOULD BE A GOOD MIRROR OF
WHAT'S TO COME IN A GOOD
FORESHADOWING EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S
TO COME ACROSS THE COUNTRY OVER
THE NEXT TWO TO THREE YEARS.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RURAL
COUNTIES THAT HAVE SMALLER
POPULATIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
CONSERVATIVE, BUT VOTING RIGHTS
GROUPS SAY THEY ABSOLUTELY
MATTER, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THESE BATTLEGROUND STATES
WHERE THE MARGINS ON A LOT OF
THESE RACES, WHETHER IT'S
GUBERNATORIAL, U.S. SENATE, OR
THE PRESIDENTIAL, ARE JUST VERY
SMALL.
THESE MARGINS ARE VERY TIGHT.
THAT'S WHY KASIE THEY'RE
WATCHING NYE COUNTY.
THE CONCERN IS THAT THIS COULD
BE UPSCALED TO OTHER
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
KASIE.
>> KYUNG LAH, QUITE A REPORT.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
>> LET'S BRING IN POLITICAL
COMMENTARIES KARI SELLERS AND
JONAH GOLDBERG JONAH, YOU SAW
KYUNG'S REPORTING RIGHT THERE.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN THE HOUSE AND
OTHER OFFICES FAIR AND SQUARE IN
NOVEMBER, THEY STILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO DO THAT.
HOW DO THEY THEN CONVINCE VOTERS
THE RESULTS WERE LEGITIMATE
AFTER THEY SPENT ALL THIS TIME
SOWING DOUBT?
>> I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY --
IT'S WORTH KEEPING IN MIND THAT
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY HAVE A THEORY OF THE CASE
OF WHAT TO DO ONCE THEY HAVE
CAUGHT THE CAR OTHER THAN TO
ACTUALLY COUNT THE BALLOTS.
AS KYUNG POINTED OUT IN HER
REPORT, THESE COUNTIES ARE
LIKELY TO GO OVERWHELMINGLY FOR
A REPUBLICAN ANYWAY, SO IF THEY
WANT TO INCONVENIENCE THEMSELVES
TO DO HAND PAPER BALLOT COUNTS,
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO GET SOME -- ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THE REAL VOTE.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD
THING.
CYBER NINJAS TRIED REALLY HARD
TO INVENT ALL SORTS OF THEORIES
AND THEY HAD TO ADMIT THEY
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING.
I'M NOT TRYING TO CONDONE THIS
OR MINIMIZE THE SPREAD OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND NONSENSE
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, BUT I
DON'T KNOW THE LEAP HAS PROVEN
THAT BECAUSE THEY BUY INTO THIS
BS NARRATIVE ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION, THAT THEY ARE THEN
GOING TO SOMEHOW STUFF BALLOTS
IN EXCESS OF WHAT THE REAL VOTE
IS.
>> BAKARI, HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
JONAH AND DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS
ARE DOING ENOUGH TO COUNTER SOME
OF THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IT
MATTERS, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
BECAUSE EVEN IN THE RURAL AREAS,
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT RUNNING IN
NEVADA OR WHEREVER IT MAY BE,
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS NOT GET
BEAT AS BAD.
SO YES, THOSE RURAL COUNTIES DO
MATTER.
DEMOCRATS ARE PAYING ATTENTION
TO THOSE COUNTIES.
YOU LOOK AT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE GREAT STATE OF NEVADA WHO
WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO THESE
RURAL COUNTIES, MEETING WITH
THESE VOTERS.
IF THERE IS FUNNY BUSINESS
THAT'S HAPPENING, BY THE HAND
BALLOTS OR IF IT'S TWO OR THREE
VOTES IN THIS PRECINCT OR TWO OR
THREE VOTES IN THAT PRECINCT BY
HAND COUNTING THE BALLOTS, THEN
YOU HAVE A REAL BIG ISSUE
BECAUSE THAT CAN SWAY AN
ELECTION.
THIS IS -- THEY ARE FIXING A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
I THINK WE HAVE TO START WITH
THE SIMPLE FACT THAT OUR
ELECTIONS WERE FAIR AND SQUARE.
IF YOU SEE ANY INCIDENTS OF
ELECTION FRAUD, MOST TIMES IT
WAS BY INDIVIDUALS VOTING
REPUBLICAN IN THEIR PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES.
WE STILL HAVE THESE ELECTION
DENIERS WHO HAVE MAJOR ROLES IN
IMPLEMENTING DEMOCRACY, AND THAT
SHOULD SCARE EVERYBODY.
ARE DEMOCRATS DOING ENOUGH?
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR